a man kneeled during Donald Trump's
replacement White House national anthem
ceremony and of course the fact that
there was a White House national anthem
ceremony would be a story in and of
itself but we're going to talk about
exactly what happened and the story is
about a man that some are calling a
national hero and yesterday I told you
that Donald Trump cancelled the
invitation of Super Bowl champion
Philadelphia Eagles players to the White
House and Trump said that the reason for
the cancellation was related to their
disrespect for the national anthem in
connection with those kneeling protests
that took place in the NFL in the last
season or two now it was ridiculous at
its face because no Eagles players
kneeled during the national anthem not
during the Super Bowl not during the
entire last football season so by
definition that reason is a joke whether
Trump knew it was a lie or is using it
ignorant Lee we don't know more likely
it was either number one that Trump
didn't want to be embarrassed because
only ten of the more than 50
Philadelphia Eagles players planned to
go or because he wanted to distract from
the terrible russia-related news over
the last 24 hours it involved Michael
Cohen and Paul Manafort that might
explain why Trump also flipped out on
Jeff Sessions on Twitter again we don't
really know what the real reason was
that the Philadelphia Eagles were
disinvited uninvited from the White
House but it really can't have anything
to do with kneeling because none of them
actually kneeled during the national
anthem last season so anyway
Trump cancels the visit says instead
he's going to hold a real patriotic
national anthem ceremony at the White
House it is going to be for real
patriots all of whom are going to stand
during the anthem and of course it'll be
open to the Philadelphia Eagles fans who
were expecting to see their heroic
players at the White House but weren't
because Trump uninvited them and Trump
actually did this he spoke about at the
rally how important it is to stand and
not to kneel during the anthem and this
is just the best because a guy at least
one guy kneels during the anthem it
ended up being a relatively small group
of people who showed up at the White
House for the stupid event and
danish news channel tv2 reported on this
guy kneeling during the entire thing at
the white house you see him in a picture
over my shoulder notice also that in all
the pictures and videos were gonna play
for you today there is not a single
non-white person period that can be
identified at this event so here's a
tweet from Danish television where they
said quote at the White House one guy in
the audience took a knee during the
national anthem at president Trump
celebration of America no Eagles event
left right after didn't want to talk we
also have video of the guy take a look
at this
[Music]
does anybody else understand the
hilarity of this more people have now
kneeled during the national anthem
ceremonies conducted at the White House
then the number of NFL players of Ana
Philadelphia Eagles players that kneeled
during games the entire 2017 season yet
the reason that this ceremony even took
place was that the Eagles weren't being
respectful to the national anthem we are
in bizarro world and every aspect of
this was just dumb it was also supposed
to be an event for all of the Eagles
fans who I guess went to DC for their
team's visit but very clearly the cloud
crowded this thing was just random
people one example is Tim furlong who's
a reporter for Philadelphia's NBC 10
station who on Twitter said I've asked
six of the fans at the White House who
was the Eagles quarterback during the
Superbowl
not one person knew so this entire thing
is the sort of propagandistic nonsense
that we see in authoritarian countries
right the sort of forced allegiance to
the flag stuff the over involvement from
leaders about exactly what you're
allowed to do either when the national
anthem plays or when there's a picture
on on the wall of Kim il-sung for
example right this is the same type of
stuff that we see in other countries
with forced patriotic patriotic sort of
tribalism and this is the administration
at large right it's a pathetic and
embarrassing joke sort of at the macro
but then even at the micro level this is
the type of stuff we're seeing and I
guess did there's a possibility that
this wasn't the only guy kneeling there
was another guy who might have been
kneeling he might have just been in a
wheelchair it wasn't totally clear CNN
was reporting on it but possibly
multiple people kneeling during a
ceremony that only is being held because
Donald Trump wants to show how
forcefully he is against kneeling during
the national anthem I mean just a
pathetic gong show that this
administration has become the video you
just finished watching was made possible
by you through the membership program
you can sign up for membership at david
pakman.com slash membership we are
viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership